let's speak now to our correspondent in
new york joe pikes what then is the
legal basis for this retrial demand joe
well the basis is a questionnaire that
all potential jurors filled in before
the gillane maxwell trial about 500
filled that questionnaire in and this
juror who got through the whole
selection process scotty david now says
that he was a victim of child sexual
abuse there was a question within that
questionnaire asking whether you or your
family and friends have ever been a
victim of
sexual abuse sexual harassment or sexual
assault now we do not know how he
answered that question but if he had
said
he was the victim of abuse he should not
have been a juror in this case that
would have been a potential bias
now this man this juror says that he
quotes flew through the questionnaire
he uh doesn't remember answering a
question about abuse but if he did
answer it he answered it honestly
certainly
both sets of lawyers on the prosecution
and on the defense side recognizes a
problem here the first law is to get in
touch with the judge to write to them
asking for an inquiry and a court
hearing in a month's time was the
government lawyers but since then in the
last hour or so gillard maxwell's team
have also been in touch with judge
nathan saying that uh the interviews and
the fact that uh scotty david was a
victim of abuse presents quotes
incontrovertible grounds for a new trial
he could potentially be in some legal
trouble if he has misled the court
although i'm sure he would deny that
anna what we could potentially see
although it is early days is the judge
declaring the first trial a mistrial and
starting again from scratch that's
something i'm sure that the government
the prosecutors here in the u.s would
want to avoid but that is what gilley
maxwell's lawyers are now calling for